البدايه من التي تعرضت للمره الثانيه منذ
بدء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا لهجوم
بالمسيرات فقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان مقاطعه موسكو وتعرضت لهجوم اوكرانيه
بثمانيه طائرات مسيره وصفت هذا الهجوم
بالارهابي الدفاع الروسيه اضافه الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت خمسه مسيرات بمنظومه بانتسير
الروسيه وثلاثه الاخرى باستخدام معدات
الحرب الالكترونيه
موسكو ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه اسفر عن اصابه
شخصين بجروح طفيفه اما موقع وريباري
العسكريه الروسيه فقال ان الهجمات على
موسكو وضواحيها تمت باستخدام مسيرات
اوكرانيات الصنع من طراز يو جي 22 هذا
وافرت رويترز بان لجنه امنيه روسيه بدات
تحقيقات في سقوط الطائرات المسيره على
مباني في موسكو وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
صورا قالت انها استهدفت منظومه بانتس ير
للدفاع الجوي مسيره في مقاطعه موسكو
تنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي رصدت سقوط هذه المسيرات والاماكن
التي استهدفتها واخر المعطيات الرسميه
نعم سلمى بالفعل يعني وفقا للمعطيات
الرسميه فان العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها تعرضت
بهجوم بثمان مسيرات بحسب وزاره الدفاع هذه
المسيرات لم تصل الى اهدافها الى اهدافها
لم تصل لا الى اي منشات للبنيه التحتيه
الحكوميه الاستراتيجيه المهمه ولم ايضا
تصب اي من المواقع العسكريه في العاصمه
موسكو بحسب المعطيات الرسميه تم اسقاط
ثلاث مسيرات باستخدام محطات رادار
الكترونيه سقطت في العاصمه موسكو خمس
مسيرات اخرى تم اسقاطها في ضواح العاصمه
موسكو باستخدام منظومات الدفاع الجوي من
طراز بانثر نحن حاليا سلما نتواجد احد
امام احد المباني التي سقطت
احدى المسيرات في العاصمه موسكو باتجاهها
هذا المبنى كما تبدو الصوره من خلفيه سلمى
حاليا لا يزال حتى هذه اللحظه على الرغم
من ان الحادث وقع
ساعات الصباح الاولى الا انه حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يزال هذا المبنى مطوق تم اجلاؤه
بشكل كامل من كل السكان حاليا لا تزال لا
يزال رجال الشرطه يطوقونهم يطوقونه من كل
مكان لا تزال هناك بعض سيارات الاسعاف بعض
حافلات اخماد الطوارئ وما الى ذلك
هنا نحن حيث نحن نتواجد احدى هذه المسيره
قامت باستهداف هذا المهبل بالسقوط الى
داخل احد النوافذ التي تقع في الطابق
السادس عشر كما واضح في الصوره هناك تحطم
لاحد الزجاج ولكن ايضا كما هو واضح فان
الاضرار التي تسبب بها هذا الهجوم على
الاقل هذا المبنى هي يعني طفيفه للغايه
اما فيما يتعلق بالخسائر البشريه فيما
يعني وفقا لتصريحات حاكم موسكو فان هناك
فقط شخصان اصيب باضرار طفيفه للغايه
يعني هذه الجروح التي يعني اصيب بها تم
معالجتها على الارض مباشره كونها طفيها
ولم يتم نقلهما حتى الى المستشفى مصادر
عسكريه كثيره سلمى تتحدث عن ان هذا الهجوم
تم
باستخدام سيارات تم اطلاقها من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع على يعني على
الفور كانت قد حملت السلطات الاوكرانيه
مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم وصفته بالارهابي مواقع
عسكريه كاريبار تتحدث عن ان تم اطلاق هذه
المسيرات تتحدث عن ان هذه مسيرات من طراز
يوجي 22 التي تقوم بانتاجها بانتاجها شركه
اوكرشات الاوكرانيه هي التي تقوم بتصنيعها
تم اطلاقها من اراضي مقاطعه سوم هذه
المقاطعه المتاخمه ايضا لمقاطعه بيل جارد
الروسيه التي يعني لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
تشهد يعني يوميا هجمات وفقا للتصريحات
الروسيه السلطات الرسميه بالمدفعيه
والقذائي في الهاون من قبل السلطات
الاوكرانيه اذا روسيا تحمل الجانب
الاوكراني مسؤوليه هذا الحادث وايضا تتحدث
عن مسيرات تم اطلاقها من الاراضي الروسيه
وليس يعني عبر ولم يتم تنفيذ هذا الهجوم
عبر مجموعات تخريبيه كما تم الحديث عن نعم
لان هذه الطائرات المسيره وفقا للمعطيات
وفقا حتى لخصائصها تستطيع التحليق لمسافه
تصلي 800 كيلو متر على الصعيد السياسي اود
الاشاره اخيرا زين الى تصريحات كانت قد
صدرت من قبل رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس
الدومه الذي اشار الى ان هذه الخطوه هي
فعليا يعني ضربه معنويه اكثر منها يعني
عسكريه ان صح التعبير خسائر بالفعل هي
خسائر يعني طفيفه للغايه ولكن هي ضربه
معنويه والهدف من ذلك حسب تعبيره هي ارساء
الفوضى في المجتمع الروسي وهذا لا يجب
السماح به حسب تعبيره لابد من تحليل ما
حدث اليوم واتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه
للحيلوله دون تكرار مثل هذه الحوادث